but I think you know just because you if
you're feeling an emotion and you kind
of being like Oh well if I just think
about it then I'll get more sad that's
you pushing the emotion away that
doesn't mean it goes away it's still
there it kind of does for me honestly
like I swear to God it looks like if I'm
sad I'm trying to be like you perfect
there's like research on this if you
like I've been in situations where I'm
like sad but if you pretend to be happy
long enough like your butt your it like
tricks your brain like to think make it
yeah like they think you're ha it thinks
you're happy but I found like if I just
sit and like complain about my problems
like I I personally have never found
that effective unless it's like maybe
you know some people have like Secrets
or like stuff they've never talked about
for years and need to tell someone but
it's like how long do you need to do
that for to the point where it almost
like it seems like it would make it
worse